logan is with us in Virginia Beach
Virginia I Logan how are you I'm good
better than I deserve what's up well I
have a question I just got through Total
Money Makeover and I also had your did
your principles of financial peace in
high school
thank you so much for all that you do
and I'm glad where I am right now have a
good start my question today is about
credit cards which you talked about it
the myths of credit cards building your
credit report and my question is if I am
a financial nerd is it okay to get a one
credit card or two credit cards to buy a
house because of how difficult it may be
to get a mortgage company that will do a
non FICO score I mean you you said you
went through our class and you read on
my but a red book right yeah okay did
you ever hear me say one time in
anything I've ever said have you ever
heard me say ever to anyone that it's a
good idea to get a credit card okay
well the answer is not gonna change with
you Logan on the the thing is this okay
some people can smoke a pack a day of
cigarettes and lived a hundred other
people died a horrible black lung death
lung cancer kills you instantaneously
almost I mean you get three months to
live once they finally catch it you
don't make it so the Surgeon General has
said that smoking is bad for your health
right right and it's it is established
it kills you
does it kill everyone no when it kills
enough people that I'm not gonna smoke a
pack a day
mm-hmm I mean no I got to tell you
there's a lot of people want to lose
weight they smoke
because it you'll drop weight when you
smoke by the way nicotine activates your
metabolism system metabolism and your
systems and it'll cause you to drop
weight so some people do it and get away
with it
but by and large most people have come
to realize that it freakin kills you any
worth the risk and that's the deal here
as a financial nerd you might get away
with it you might live to 100 and never
pay a dime and interest on a credit card
but I got to tell you what yours rare is
a freaking unicorn if you do as most
people fall into this trap of believing
like all the other people believe and
then they end up with the same results
that all the other people have broken
and debt all because they want to build
a credit score because it might be
difficult to live without a credit score
it is difficult to live without a credit
score by the way okay I mean if I go get
a cell phone I I have to put up money
but I have to put a deposit because I
don't have a credit score if my my
homeowners insurance my car insurance
rates are higher because I don't have a
credit score anytime I get ready do
anything people look at me cross-eyed
like I'm an idiot
and I've got enough money to write a
check and buy their whole freaking life
but they still look at me like I'm an
idiot because I didn't fall for the same
mythology that the entire rest of the
culture fell for and and so my
suggestion is don't take up smoking and
it didn't worth the risk and I wouldn't
take up using credit cards it's not
worth the risk that's my suggestion and
always has been and so I have no credit
cards in my pocket I have to debit cards
in my pocket one of them's got shut down
this weekend because apparently somebody
bought something in Vietnam on one of my
debit cards so I'm not immune like
anybody else is and they shut it down on
me this weekend and so I had this thing
in my pocket called money and I used
that to pay for my gas at the gas
station because the little debit card
didn't work because it was shut down
because somebody bought something in
Vietnam and old Dave hadn't been in
Vietnam lately so apparently that was
what's known as a fraudulent transaction
so guess what that will happen with your
credit card - by the way as the exact
same fraud protection as your debit card
does but I mean you can go get a credit
card and you can
the credit score and you can be normal
but keep in mind look around you what
normal looks like normals broke and sir
you don't be normal
your goal is total weirdness I do not
want to be normal normal is I've got a
student loan that's been around so long
I think it's a pet I've discovered
bondage and American distress normal is
the number one cause of divorce in North
America Day money fights and money
problems stress on the marriage in the
money area number one cause why do you
want be normal that's what everybody
else does I know this is my exactly my
point and you know you live among a
group of people who are completely
freaking broke what riding around
looking like they're not but broke don't
be normal and don't expect me to give
you advice that would cause you to be
normal because it won't be happening
here hey you guys Rachael Cruz here hope
you are enjoying the Dave Ramsey show
and did you know that I have my very own
YouTube channel yes that's right it's
kind of better than the Dave Ramsey
channel don't tell them I said that I'm
kidding I'm kidding
so subscribe and there's lots of videos
about life and money so while you're at
it if you want to check out a video then
you can check out how to do a monthly
budget it's one of the best videos out
there
you